hi there so I saw this and probably many
of you have seen this open AI was
demonstrating at msbuild a basically a
GPT two language model but trained not
on language but on code on python code
open source code from github and so the
idea is that the model learns to produce
code and we'll just have a short look at
the clip they they have here I'll link
the entire clip down so this is what the
human types def is palindrome so the
function name the argument and the dog
string and other model is asked to
produce the rest of the function and
check out so it's pretty good right this
is actually to check whether this is a
basic check whether a string is a
palindrome as long as you can ensure
that s is a string and so on so the
model learned this you can still say
maybe that's just interpolating from you
know something like this is surely
negative rep goes somewhere so they go
further and they try to say okay please
give me a function where the palindromes
so return a list indices for elements
that are palindromes and at least seven
characters and I personally have
searched for this function on github and
it does not exist so what does the model
produce pretty cool so this is first of
all a list comprehension in Python which
is reasonably complicated right and you
can see there is this length filter that
is greater or equal to seven and it
refers actually back to the is
palindrome function that it that it
wrote before that's pretty cool now this
is not like a language model producing
as far as I understand producing this
basically letter by letter or word by
word this goes over the constraints of
Apps abstract syntax trees so it is I I
think that's what's happening they don't
they don't have a paper to go along
though I will look into more papers of
that sort they do kind of constrain the
model to actually produce valid code but
of course which variables go where and
so on that that's that is completely up
to the model and you see here it
understands completely what the user
wants now of course these examples might
be cherry picked right but it's even for
cherry picked examples still pretty
impressive
as I said I could not find this
particular function so they post two
classes here data classes item and order
and now the model is asked to compute
the total order price which is a method
of the of the of the order class and
they stop here so this is what the human
enters the human enters that just the
name of the function
not even the dock string and the model
comes up with the following compute the
total price of the order including the
palindrome so it does all of that by
itself including the dock string just
from the method now you can see pretty
much what's happening here it's kind of
like the GPT 2 language model so what it
does is probably it from the method name
it derives this doc string compute total
price right that's a lot of programmers
do this of the order order is of course
the name of the class of self and here's
as including the palindrome discount and
that is probably somewhat pattern
matched to other functions that so have
some sort of discount or something like
this or for one argument that is a
number but the fact that it is also able
see it adds up the total price per item
and it basically discounts every item
now it cannot work out that palindrome
discount should mean that every item
should be a palindrome that's the only
thing it can't work out it just applies
the discount to every single item now
they go ahead and kind of change that
and write the doc strings themselves
such that it is clear that apply the
discount to items whose name or
palindromes now the model is again asked
to complete this and absolutely crazy if
it's a palindrome then multiply it with
the discount and if it's not a
palindrome then just at the price and
this final touch here that's one minus
the palindrome discount is added by the
programmer so you can see that that this
goes towards kind of a symbiosis of
human and machine in this way I don't
think the a I will replace programmers
but it certainly is going to be very
helpful to UM to automate some of the
things or give you suggestions right for
a further thing
that you have to do over and over again
now I think a lot of a lot of these rely
on the fact that a lot of programming is
redundant still a lot of people name the
function and then in the dock string
they basically repeat the function
because they've already intelligently
named the function so technically there
doesn't need to be a doc string but then
whatever your style guide comes in it
says there needs to be a doc string
every argument must be described every
argument must have a description and a
help string and that type even though it
is completely obvious from the names
what they do so if it is completely
obvious I would argue you don't need a
doc string and this is kind of
additional information that this model
is able to to actually sort of make use
of right so the fact that a lot of these
functions you can already the doc string
is sort of already the implementation of
the function almost so the the distance
there is not it's not like you can you
can say whatever you want and yeah so
you can see here when it's asked to
print the receipt it just works out so
it's it's printing it's doing format
strings and whatnot so it's just learned
to do that I would argue again this this
works you couldn't just put anything
like doc string language is a very
specific type of language that
programmers use where they basically
already sort of implement the method in
the doc string and then the the body of
the method is just the the then really
specific code but as of that yeah
there's a lot of information already in
the doc string in the naming of the
function and it's still pretty
impressive right so yeah I just want to
show you that this already is available
even though not in you know as big of a
form we can't write giant functions for
you you can't write function bodies but
there are some machine learning based
completions already available so kite is
one of them and tab nine is the other
one that I use for now both are close
sources I understand it so that's a bit
of a downer there but these are exactly
kind of GPT language models learned on a
lot of code so they can kind of guess
what you want and interpolate with your
variables in there and so on I also
found this
when I search this comparison here kite
versus Table nine and you see it starts
off yeah but these are I think these are
kind of auto-generated so when you look
at the video you get tab nine is correct
that kite it's an actual video review of
a kite yeah so you know who knows but
what I wanted to do is basically show
you a bit of the power of tap nine
let me get this out of the way so a
while back ago I live coded this session
right here where where I implemented a
sentiment classifier from scratch using
hugging face libraries and I thought we
would just play around in here a bit to
see what the tab nine could do for us
all right so I have tab nine in here
together with a bunch of other stuff I
have to admit so I'm not sure how this
is going to turn out so let's say we
wanted to compute the loss here let's
say we wanted to compute square loss
square loss you see that tab nine
immediately kind of turns out I've not
tried this entire impressed so it says
it estimates loss here and no that's
maybe not what I want so I'll go with
square now this is a language server
suggestion so and you can see right here
even though I don't have these variables
kind of tab nine will suggest train loss
and validation loss so let me start a
new file right here just to see what we
can get this thing to do without doing
anything so and so let's say we'll
import OS and we'll say if name so tab
nine auto suggests that and it although
suggests that we should write main here
right and it knows that a lot of people
then call a function called main so we
should probably do that def main right
sorry
okay let's go with the following we'll
say we'll try the same thing they did
right so we'll say we have a data class
order it has let's say price float and a
name string and order one is an order
with the price of five and a name of
hello and we can print CC tab nine tab
nine if you can see that it's closely
suggested to print order dot price order
1 dot price so it can you can see that
we kind of want that how do I select
that right here see order 2 equals so
we'll get another order right here
seven hello with order - let's do that
orders equals order one order - so total
price total price equals zero or order
in Wow did you see that in now I can't
get it anymore in orders that's what tab
nine says total price plus equals order
dot price so it is already pretty smart
I would argue print and there you saw
that total price was suggested okay I
don't know how to select this but I'll
figure it out I'm not that advanced yet
so you can see this already sort of
works and I think it's really cool
already and I'm very excited to see what
kind of how far people can push this
because I think this code generation
kind of inferring what you want is only
at the beginning right now and it's for
sure going to come more and yeah with
that bye bye
[Music]
you